it's going back to we're talking about
earlier with the trans people and you're
saying like you empathize more with a
lot with them because of their like
feelings and stuff like
i'm paraphrasing right
but so i have a question i personally
like would not support a law that
allowed trans people in the girls
bathrooms
and i'm going to tell you why it's not
for the reason you think it's because
when it's not because like some trans
people like like seriously like look
like a girl i wouldn't really care
you're in a stall whatever but the issue
is when you when you talk about a policy
you have to think about people
taking it to the extreme
because at some point someone in the u.s
is going to take that to the extreme
like there are crazy people and that's
where like i think laws are supposed to
protect you right and i would not want
um a girl to get assaulted
because a man is claiming to be a woman
and going into the girl's bathroom yeah
like if they're not actually a part of
the community
yeah i totally understand that so
because of that like i just think that
that trans people should either have
their own bathrooms or go to what they
were assigned at birth because i i and
it's easy like it's easy to say oh like
think about their feelings and stuff but
what i wouldn't want to see is somebody
get assaulted because in the name of
feelings
okay i understand that yeah but
how are you going to feel seeing a trans
man for example
full blown on testosterone for god knows
how many years full-blown beard muscles
all that walking into a woman's bathroom
you won't be able to tell right
and immediately women are going to react
negatively
let's be honest i think we can say
peacefully that at least a majority of
the trans community
if not all of them
genuinely are not going to do that
they're not going to assault people
people however who are going to use that
terror to their advantage
to assault people now that's a whole
different story but how often does that
happen well yeah but i think it's
because we like bringing up the whole
how often does that happen with me every
time i bring up an issue but how often
do we really think a trans person is
going to be popping up into one of these
bathrooms to purposely assault somebody
well i think the point isn't how often
does it happen i the law is there to
protect you
okay that's that's the purpose of the
law
and i think like leah thomas looks like
a dude to me i'm gonna be like i don't
oh yeah he does leah thomas doesn't like
like i i don't think that leah thomas
even slightly resembles a female and if
i saw the atomos in a bathroom even
though he's been on testosterone or like
whatever estrogen estrogen yeah whatever
for a year i would feel so uncomfortable
if he whipped his like dick
like i would i would feel in a locker
room and i i think i should legally be
protected from that like i shouldn't
have to see men's parts in the women's
bathrooms
there were two cases that i i spoke on
about a year ago in america one was a
a man who identified as a woman
at a spa
in the sauna
and
female changing room
going into the changing room and then
whipping off his towel
and there was a woman in there who had a
young child
i guess her daughter was like 12
in there too with her and she came out
was like there's a guy in there walking
around with his thing swinging yeah
saying that he's a woman
and they wouldn't do anything about it
because they were like ma'am he
identifies as a woman that's a woman
second one
was there's a waxing company in america
um who does like female brazilian yeah
and one of the person one of the people
got upset about that because the
esthetician said that they were not
trained to do the waxing that they asked
for
is it that one no it's when the guy came
in to get a wax
the guy or the girl
biologically you could just say the
person
like it's really not that hard the
biological man went into a woman's
waxing salon and asked for a wax
they said no we don't wax men this is a
female wax salon and he wanted to sued
them for transphobia
yeah and i had seen that story and the
esthetician said herself that she was
not capable of doing that because she's
not trained for it not even just the
company but like the woman itself i had
looked very deeply into this i fully
agree with that the whole situation i
get that like if the these people are
not trained for it
they're not gonna do it and if it's for
women only it's for women only just
accept that like
nobody when it comes to this person in
particular
i'm not done talking if you kept
listening then you would have known that
i was going to say something
for this person in particular who is
trans and identifies as a woman
what they should have done was look for
a waxing center that is more inclusive
and not only um experienced than just
working with cisgender women
that don't have like bottom top surgery
whatever it may be that it's up to them
to do that research at the end of the
day so then do you agree like them back
to the bathrooms like that they can be
women only and biological women only
when it comes to bathrooms again a
little bit teeter-totter with that
because um at least in the east coast
like you see a lot of like gender
neutral bathrooms
so like
i'm just like okay as long as it's
inclusive like you know as long as
whoever is not comfortable going to
either bathroom regardless of their
gender
if they have a third option i think that
is a good thing
um
so if anything i probably would agree
with you to a certain degree
um i think we just have to be
a little realistic because when it comes
to the whole like assigned at birth
thing like going to the bathroom
according to your assigned sex
we can't really do that with like trans
men going into a women's bathroom okay
first of all can i just say something
like
this whole assigned at birth thing
is a nonsensical argument
and this whole cis thing is a
nonsensical argument
um
a cisgender person is somebody who is
born woman or man and identifies as
woman or man
no
you have a man what time does this end
yeah
oh you in for a long night but i'm
really not we don't
listen as men and women
we don't have to take on other people's
terminologies for us right so if
somebody's going to attempt to give
a man
a title
as a man
i don't have to take a towel
don't tell me a cisgendered man
i'm a man i don't i don't i don't need
to take your title so when people just
throw out these terms that oh a
cisgender man is like you are putting
titles on people that don't even accept
your titles like if i decided to put a
title upon you that you never accepted i
don't think that's fair but the thing is
what i've noticed is with the
quote-unquote trans community
they feel as if they can give people
titles right that they don't even accept
themselves and it's just like i don't
think that's fair because that now says
that your arrogance and your ego has got
out of control where you think you can
now label somebody who doesn't even
accept attack i'm a man i'm not a
cisgendered man i'm a man okay it's
really that simple if you call yourself
a woman someone says oh
pearl you're a cisgendered woman is that
the title that you give yourself or is
it the title that they put upon you
yeah
no
does that make sense yeah no that makes
sense because you're saying it's like
disrespectful to like of course to just
label somebody yeah
because but the thing is it seems like
it's okay when it comes to the trans
community they're allowed to label other
people whereas they've labeled
themselves yeah they've given themselves
a title
all right what do you think
[Laughter]
you good jessica
we can talk about this just listen to
this dude go off no biggie
um so
who do you think
came up with the terminology
uh
no it came from a german sexologist in
the 90s okay um and this man is he
considered himself
cisgender yeah all right yeah cisgender
he was he was funding that he was born a
man
and raised as a man okay and
fully considered himself he him whatever
yeah
so
we can't just sit here and think that
the lgbt community is out here just
labeling other people because we're not
we're going based off of well there is
terminology that was created by
sexologists
to properly
refer to other people what does cis mean
then
cis man born male
goes with being identified as male same
thing with women born as a woman and
goes with being a woman
like this stuff just sounds like
nonsense to me it's like like because it
just sounds like like delusion because
you're saying like you have to do all
these terms to say the same thing you
don't have to no you're right you you
really no ain't nobody forcing none of
these [ __ ] to go with any of
these terminology however i do that to
be more inclusive to people
by choice because i want to be more
respectful and i want to be more
inclusive towards people who feel like
they are not being represented do you do
you feel like we always have to be
inclusive to people
that depends on the situation okay
genuinely because like sometimes i think
like some people should be excluded
because you know what you know what i
know like like what if like what if like
um okay let's take let's take um
like black lives matter
like then when people said oh all lives
matter
that kind of what about that like do you
don't you feel like do you feel like
like in that case they were trying to
exclude
do i feel like black people were trying
to exclude other races yeah no no or
like like not at all
because that is the issue that people
have with black lives matter they think
that we're saying that other people
don't matter we're not we're trying to
emphasize that we matter too yeah as
much as other lives but we are being
oppressed the most out of anybody else
based on our race but that's why i'm
saying like that's why the movement like
like if
like the movement isn't about other
races as much as it as it is about like
black people yeah and that in that case
in a way you're excluding other races
but we have to because we have to
capitalize on our i'm not taking away
from that but i'm saying i think there's
some cases where people should be
excluded and that's one of them yes yes
that is absolutely it right i genuinely
feel that way about plenty of situations
in which a minority is being oppressed
and other people need to recognize that
this is not their battle so but that's
what i'm saying like in the case of
women i think trans people should be
excluded from
us because they're not women and like we
have our own issues and we have things
that we fight for and are specifically
to women right i don't think you get to
pretend to be a woman just like i can't
pretend to be black right
like i don't like i don't think you get
to like take away you get to take away
our awards you get to take away
um our our athletics
you get to take away our
all of our women's only spaces
okay they're they're taking these away
from us and just like if there was like
you know black lives matter if someone
said okay let's make it white lives
matter like like that would be that that
people would be in an uproar they would
be yeah you know but now um i just
remembered this whole thing um when it
comes to like the swimmers right like
how you brought up um leah thomas and
how this person had
i guess they blew away the competition i
assumed like david oh yeah
in first place
90 seconds behind or some crazy stuff
like that here's the thing with yeah
here's the thing with battling um
biological
uh situations and
being put in a certain category for
competition right
when we look at someone like michael
phelps
he does not produce lactic acid in his
legs okay but he blows away the
competition every single time because he
can't produce it that we know what like
that lactic acid in our calves feels
like i'm gonna be honest
so lactic acid is what builds up after
um long-term training right so it's like
the burning sensation that you feel in
your calves or like your legs more
likely
um because he can't produce that he's
already at an advantage so naturally he
will have a much longer stamina however
he's been allowed to um compete his
entire swimming career
so does that mean that he should not
have been allowed to compete because he
was at an advantage at that point and
this is just a question i'm asking like
not whether or not i believe that he
doesn't he says he doesn't not produce
it he produces half as much lactic acid
which is a huge difference compared to
the average person i think that's okay
that's like
i know a girl that's six five
okay okay like and she had a huge
advantage when it came to recruiting
right if you're 6'5 you have a d1 but
that's an expectation for sports
your height like your height and build
are the two things that coaches and
recruiters look at the most right right
but i'm saying i think there's a
difference between having an advantage
but you're still you're still a
biological manners biological woman okay
like i think there's a difference
between just having an advantage you
know amongst your group okay and
having them come into our group and
blowing all of us out of the water okay
because like imagine imagine chesca you
know how hard we train we train so hard
yeah
bro i've been in this damn sport for
nine years so i i understand now imagine
working your whole life and you having
to sit the bench this year because of
dudes in front of you
like like
it's not it's not fair i mean no matter
what i'm not going
to um
disrespect that person's identity and
all that i will be upset i will be
honest because it's like i know at the
end of the day if that person's not been
on estrogen for long enough they're not
going to have the same
even close to biological build as me and
me knowing that i have trained so hard
to get to whatever point i need to be
it's going to be done up for me i don't
think there's ever a point because let's
let's even take height okay
i'm
i'm tall i'm the top one percent of hype
for females
amongst men i'm in the top 15 percent of
height
the reason that i compete well you see
me compete i'm strong and i'm tall yeah
and i have long arms but amongst men i'm
not that strong i'm not that tall and i
don't have that long of arms
because 15 percent of men are taller
than me i'd be blown out i would have no
opportunity
and it's like how is that fair
i get you like no i don't i don't
disagree like i i fully see both sides
of the situation because no matter what
i want to respect um
trans people wanting to be able to
compete now i i'll be honest like back
in high school at least before i did at
least a little bit more research on this
right i believed that they should have
had their own um
like league you know yeah but the reason
why i believe this is because i'm one of
those people where it's like if you
don't like the way something is
do something about it right so something
that upset me constantly
was seeing um
trans women get upset about not being
able to be a model for victoria's secret
right um now personally i could give a
[ __ ] about victoria's secret they're not
even that good no more uh it's all fenty
baby but
um i felt like you know what if these
people aren't accepting you
do something else make your own company
make your own lingerie company if you
want like
if you want make your own trans modeling
company or agency i mean right because i
genuinely feel like we have more of a
platform to do what we want right at the
end of the day it's not the same as like
the 60s you know where it like someone
would shoot us down for it right like
and because of that like i i again i
don't really see what i mean i i could
see the argument for abortion right like
and i'm sure feminists like would rather
have more and more abortion rights fine
like i i understand that at least but
outside of that like
i can't see what on earth we're fighting
for like to be honest like what we need
feminism for
because i guess things are quite equal
now yeah there's nothing stop as you
just said there's nothing stopping us
from going and starting whatever company
we want to start i'll tell you what it
is like but that's why i was saying
what we're fighting for more is just
going against assault and rape and
um
like bodily autonomy like i said like i
really think that's our main um thing
because you know what i realized like
even when i speak to other people about
women's rights
none of us are really complaining about
like
you know [ __ ] like not getting paid
enough or like not getting opportunities
or anything like that if anything some
of us are getting a little bit more
opportunities because we're pretty and
like this and that you know i i think i
hear girls say that all the time on my
show they talk about pay gap yeah i've
brought it up
it's a pay gap i will i won't go against
you they know why there's a pickup
though po that's the question
um
so
does my voice irritate you
i don't think he's i think he's just
trying to i'm actually asking the
question like does like do they know the
reason for the pay gap a lot of times no
they think it's like the patriarchy or
society right but it's not it's women's
choices right
but um the most high-paying jobs
right
women aren't necessarily willing to do
them but there are plenty of situations
where women will be in the same um
what's the word um same position i'll
just say like same job position as a lot
of other men within the same company
let's say
that realize that they are getting paid
less than their male counterparts who
even may have been at the company for a
far less amount of time than they have
been right now that that's more of a
company issue that's illegal i can't say
that like that's like a statewide or
country-wide issue why that is chesca
though
because of personality differences
between men and women men are more
disagreeable
so if they get offered a salary they're
more likely to say f that i'll go work
for another and that will screw you or
they're more likely to try and negotiate
a better deal yeah or negotiate or say
i'm not gonna take that
and like in that case i think i'm just
around a lot of ambitious women then
because i feel like i don't know anybody
like that but like i said i can only
speak from my perspective it's kind of
like it's okay in this conversation
right
who who's more pleasant to talk to me or
sarah
you even said no but it's because of
personality differences right like he's
more disagreeable i'm more agreeable
because i'm a woman and we naturally
like we
i'm disagreeable
but but it's not it's not a bad thing
right because you know sarah can have
some really cool moments for like on the
internet you know but
but like but like you see what i'm
saying like it's the same thing in in a
company like like sarah would probably
be more likely to say oh screw that i'll
go work for someone else or i'm not
going to take that job or i'm like good
enough fine
i would
in that it's true because i would in my
workplace i'd be like hang on a minute
so i'm doing this i'm doing that and i'm
doing that and this is what you're
paying me
i know some or i'll go down below i know
a place that wants me for the same job
but they're going to pay me x
what are you willing to do about that
right well and and the the thing is even
with my channel i i run all of my a lot
of my decisions through men because i
know they're naturally better at that
yeah and they can get you the best deal
yeah like like um we're talking about
bringing on a producer now and i'm
having my manager talk to them because
do you drive what do you drive
i'm saying so there's a reason why when
men go to a mechanic and women go to a
mechanic women get charged more than men
yeah right because the men are like what
it's not what no but i know no my other
mechanic can no no that's not that women
were like how much is it okay yeah but
you see like that's not patriarchy
that's personality differences no i
totally agree with that like um
me on the other hand
i know how to handle those types of
situations but i think that's because i
was raised by my dad and i have dated
guys who give me insight on these kinds
of things right you know like when it
comes to cars for example if i were to
have a car a mechanic is never gonna get
me
right just know that these [ __ ]
are never gonna get me yeah but um but
that's the thing like
we don't prioritize teaching women these
kinds of things at the end of the day
either you know like
we have to think about it like it's very
stereotypical like dad teaches
son how to throw a baseball and how to
fix a car and the daughter's gonna go
play with the doll or whatever like we
naturally in society we are a little bit
more traditional we're not thinking
about teaching our kids these things
until it's like too late half the time
well i don't think it's a bad thing i
don't think we should have to try to
change how we are because i know i don't
i don't think so i think it's just um
important to keep in mind
that
these things are less like gender-based
and more just like survival skills right
like knowing how to not get
ripped off by your mechanics so that
your car can make it longer kind of
situate like that's just something you
should teach your kid period yeah but
like i don't know i think it's just more
gender-based but you do have to
understand that when a mechanic sees a
woman walk in and when he sees a man
walk in he's thinking two different
things
yeah he is he's too he's he and he and
if he has looked your car over
and he's looked the man's car over even
if he's trying to you know get the best
deal out of both of you he's gonna he's
going to approach the situation with a
little bit more tact when it comes to
the man over the woman have you ever
seen the
tick tock trend where you call your dad
and tell him
i saw a tic toc where a woman said to
her her guy that the guy charged her in
a mechanic to actually pump in the tires
because like the air is like free and
she was like yeah i paid like a hundred
dollars
he went and he said what he went nuts
but that's what i'm saying though is
that like we should make it less
gender-based and more like this is
something we should teach our kids so
that they don't get ripped off
regardless of their gender right
um it's the same thing with like just
basic life skills like cooking we don't
expect men to cook but
there may come a time where that
[ __ ] is going to live alone
men cook all the time in the caribbean
yeah that's nice and all but that we can
tell that that's not the case everywhere
right
i don't think like women i don't know a
lot of women that really like cook like
that i'm i'm i'm the black one
damn shame dude
because no matter what regardless of
gender you need to know how to sustain
yourself
you have to know how to cook clean
whatever it may be like regardless of
your gender if you don't know the sheer
basics of survival i lived by myself
since i was like 21 years old yeah so i
had to know how to cook and how to do
all these things and you know i just
i had to learn so the other the other
thing you said was like bodily autonomy
is like sexual assault and like grape
that sort of thing
but i'm just cute like what laws
because the way i look at it is again
due to personality differences like men
are more disagreeable and that's why men
in general like commit more crimes
because of that person out like men are
naturally more aggressive yeah right i
agree but um
but that's that's something you can't
really change but like in general in
most states grape you go to jail for
sexual assault you you can you go in the
west you mean i i would actually
advocate for longer prison sentences for
people that do actually i would advocate
for the death penalty
but see
the fact that they can get out or like
not even like so i'm i'm the type of
person where
if somebody is going to get jailed i
would also want them to get rehab of
some sort right because as long as
they're sitting in a jail cell and not
getting any kind of like rehabilitation
or education on how to fix themselves
and not be an [ __ ] like
don't get me wrong that everybody can be
fixed in that sense but at least
understand what they did wrong yeah like
these problems are always going to
happen they're not going to come out of
jail fully reformed right like let's be
honest i think they don't come out of
jail like i literally think if you if
you
grape someone and i'm not talking about
i'm talking about like you you pull a
girl off the street great drive down
alley yeah yeah that's sort of great
if you do that or if you
touch a child's death penalty in pearl's
world pro if you promise
yeah to say this talking about this i
was watching a video the other day
do you know a map
is a map what's a map um
i remember seeing that all over twitter
for the longest but it's a minor
attracted person yeah
so there's a new terminology now for
mine people that are attracted to miners
and they're calling a map minor
attracted person and then the way that
they refer to boys and girls is like a
hot dog or a pizza
that's disgusting it is well and that's
that's honestly though why i'm against
sex ed in schools
i think i think if if they
i i i think
you got to look at it from a predator's
point of view that's that's giving like
predators access to children 100 like
and and like but how so because you're
you're you're basically teaching kids
how to have sex jessica
but that doesn't mean that the children
are consenting to these full-blown
adults that are engaging with them okay
and putting them in these compromising
situations okay so say say you're this
is a weird like way to look at it but
pretend you're a predator for a second
you're trying to you're trying to get a
kid okay because that's kind of how you
have to look at it from like a pair like
i'm
you know you want to protect your kids
100 so so if you were a predator what
are ways you could get access to kids
right one you can go and work in where
the kids are yeah you work where the
kids are and so and i've had a situation
where i had a coach that like um he
would wait till girls turned 18
and try to hook up with us so i had like
a coach that i trained like a lot with
one-on-one for like years and i'd look
back and i thought he was testing the
waters like throughout the years where
he would like say things that were kind
of like
like i don't know just out of pocket
like right and and really weird in
hindsight to say to like a 15 16 year
old girl do you think he was like
grooming yeah oh he totally oh my god he
totally was but like i'm just someone i
always like assume the best i'll just be
like oh he didn't mean it like that or
like whatever but when you know he said
what did he say to me he he would like
ask me about
like stuff with like
who i was dating and like that like to
test the water see how i reacted and
then to keep push like pushing it
pushing and pushing it until then we
and he would do this to other girls too
till we would turn 18 and then try to
hook up with us right
and um
and i just see like sex ed is like
giving predators the opportunity to do
that but the thing is they're going to
do that regardless of the course being
given right now let's not make it
teaching children sex ed is for
awareness not teaching them how to have
sex it's just awareness right
understanding bodily autonomy these are
the parts that should not be touched
especially like whether it be from
another child or an adult it should not
happen whatsoever and it would be a way
as teaching them like defend yourself
like not necessarily like fight to the
death the thing is though none of you
have children and i'm not like that's
not in a disrespectful way but when you
actually have children
your
your um
your mindset changes
when you actually have one in your
vicinity all the time
your mindset changes as to how because
because there's
there's talking about innocence and
they're seeing it on a day-to-day basis
and when i see my sons in it i grew up
with my son when i see my son's
innocence and i see what he's like the
the feelings that i have towards
anyone who was even going to attempt to
take his innocence away
i know i would level the planet i would
level this whole planet do you know what
i mean and so
a lot of the time
people talk about these things with
children oh but sexy you don't know what
it's like to take away a child's
innocence or you don't know what it
looks like to see innocence on a
day-to-day basis once you take it away
they can't get it back right you can't
get it back get it back and like i don't
understand like why does the school know
when the best time is to tell a kid
about that stuff like as as a parent you
know your kid better than anyone 100
people you know if if he's like
every kid is different and needs to be
parented differently and as a parent
like you're going to know what what kid
is wild and you're going to want to tell
that to sooner and what one can be
innocent until they're 16 17. like like
i have i have you know four sisters and
i could tell you like one sister maybe
needed to have that talk as soon as
possible another sister she could have
waited until she was 18. it would never
have been an issue because she was
innocent up until that time
yeah because it's just like there's
personality
you were going to know more than a
school ever is going to or
i fully agree but that's why i brought
up earlier that there's going to be a
difference between the school explaining
it from a scientific perspective right
versus our parents
you know sitting down and actually
having to talk with us and saying like
how it should be carried out you know
like whether or not like
you shouldn't be super sexually active
or you have to use condoms and so on and
so forth right like do you do you think
evidence matters
so do you think like if if i would say
there's very little evidence that sex ed
actually helps kids
reduce in pregnancies outside of wedlock
um so do you do you think if there's
very little evidence that it helps
that maybe it's not effective
i think it's something that would
probably just have to be researched
further before we could even come to
that conclusion
sorry sorry
um i'm more so somebody who
wants more quantitative and qualitative
research at the same time when it comes
to this kind of stuff i fully believe in
like long-term research and this kind of
stuff because we can't make that
decision until like there's even like if
we started this search now right like
let's say we took a bunch of fifth
graders and um
you know looked at each school
curriculum curriculum in each state and
studied them for 10 years that's still
not going to give us enough evidence
well you realize it's been implemented
around the 70s that's what yeah so we
have that's a lot of
data to go off of but the problem is
that every state is so different even
school curriculums in the same state are
so different right right like they
prioritize different ways of teaching it
like
i would say that my sex ed program was
great for um our age group because again
they looked at it from such a scientific
perspective when we first started out
right right they're just like this is
what boys have this is what girls have
girls can have a period and this is how
you take care so what evidence would you
need to like disprove something
disprove so like like so your opinion is
like like and this could be with
anything but sometimes i feel like
regardless of the evidence like people
believe what they're going to believe
right so so my question is like what
evidence do you really need to see to
change an opinion on something if
anything
like how many studies would it take like
if i if i after this interview sat down
and taught you a study ten studies i
probably will i'm gonna be honest i
don't i don't get a lot of free time i
probably won't but if i if i sat down
and sent you 10 studies from 10
different states that all
indicate that sex ed in schools equals
more sex more unplanned pregnancies more
this more that would that change your
mind or would you i would have to look
at um
where those things are coming from
that's my po like i like i said that's
why i look at both quantitative and
qualitative because right quality really
is a lot but quantity matters in the
sense that are they all
quality so then for you pearl what would
sex education look like where would it
come from parents like i just think the
the government has no business in doing
that do you understand this also some
parents are absolutely [ __ ] given um
some parents are not there
i mean i i agree with you it's not a
perfect it's never going to be a perfect
system but i just think how can a
stranger there's nobody that is
more incentive to make that kid turn out
to be a good person than the parents
there's so then what okay but there are
[ __ ]
let's think about it in this sense like
how society looks down on people who are
more sexually positive like such as like
people with only fans and all that
would you feel
what would you say would you feel more
comfortable knowing that there would be
a lot of only fans models out there
teaching their kids uh-huh like you know
what i don't believe they should be only
fans in the first place
okay that doesn't answer the question am
i comfortable with them teaching that
yeah i mean no i wish they wouldn't
but like i just again i think that
there's nobody with a vested more of a
vested interest in the kid turning out
okay and i would guess that at some
point and i would guess at some point
like i don't know i've talked to a
decent amount of likes not not only fans
models but strippers that say i would
never encourage my kid to do this yeah
and so does that mean they know that
it's
wrong they have no it's that it's
something that they're too young to
understand at that point
because that is where there's a little
more emotion involved when it comes to
like stripping or um looking at sexual
content online as opposed to just
talking about again the scientific
foundation of what sex is right like
like i said like when it comes to
teaching children this they're just
saying like
this is what grown-ups do yeah and this
is how you can have a child yeah right
and this is how you practice safe sex
meanwhile when you're consuming sexual
content online that's a whole different
ballpark that you're working on i just
wouldn't want my oh my gosh i wouldn't
want my kid don't teach my kid how to
have sex don't do that i don't think
they're teaching the kid how to have sex
i think they're telling them they're
telling them
sex they're telling them about saying
they're probably not saying this is
where my penis goes
banging them in front of the kids
let's talk about it this way okay let me
let me teach them how to do drugs safely
yeah let's let's give them the tools if
they ever do drugs do it safe like if i
had okay so like the dare program you
would be against that bro yeah i get
that
what's the dare program the dare program
is like i said nothing drug is so
something something whatever there is
like all over the country and they tell
us about what drugs are gateway drugs
and what the hardcore drugs are and why
we shouldn't touch them and what the
sentences are if we were ever caught
with them and that kind of stuff right
okay
i mean i i i'd like to talk to my own
son about drugs like i just i'm a [ __ ]
and i'd like to talk to him about sex
so that's why it should be it should be
the family like why is the government
but not everybody has a family that
cares about that is probably the problem
i think that's the reason why that ever
became a concept people have got adults
out there that give birth to them and
don't give birth to them not everybody's
meant to be a parent let's just be
honest i agree i agree but i just think
again it's going back to the incentives
yeah like there's nobody that is more
incentive than a kid turning out okay
like but there's far more people in this
world that are truly not meant to be
parents than we think
right like
there's a reason why there's so many
this is the reason why the world looks
like it's burning right now because so
many people have such different morality
and different perspectives now there's
nothing wrong with that because the
world would be a boring place if we were
all on the same page right like i feel
like
i think we have to have our different
senses kids deserve a two-parent i i i i
think they're nice but unfortunately not
everybody's gonna get that there needs
to be some core things that we all agree
on yeah i don't think everyone should be
the same and think the same yeah but i
do need to be some like core things that
we agree on yeah yeah i i get what
you're saying jessica that the whole
world would be boring isn't all the same
i get that but i do think there are some
core things that all humans regardless
of race religion politics the problem is
that actually we both have different
core beliefs on certain things right
like abortion for example that already
opens up a whole can of worms
so
you think it's okay then
to kill babies in the womb
my point is that
abortion is murder
i agree i agree i think it's murder like
it doesn't
what my original point was that yeah
yeah everybody is going to think that
their opinion matters the most and that
they have the most moral value compared
to the other person but none of us can
determine that absolutely none of us are
subject to die on our hill
no matter what but it doesn't [ __ ]
matter at the end of the day
so then does it come does it come back
to you know what you do your thing i'll
do mine as long as you don't encroach
upon my human rights and i don't
encroach upon yours i fully believe that
but that's how i've always felt from the
start i feel like as long as what you're
doing is not harming yourself right
other people or animals
gucci go do whatever the hell you want
that's how we're all we're still friends
right we agree on nothing
we agree on nothing
but that is genuinely my point as long
as you're not harming yourself or other
people and animals
you're good to go dog yeah like don't
just don't put anybody in a compromising
situation
yeah no i agree